in Everly situations arrive a rice where
there may be conflict among your team
members and that may impact the
productivity of the team so I was asking
people for some examples and and how to
deal with that situation so I'll start
off with that first I mean I think that
we all know we heard it while we were at
the GSB that you know diversity is why
we're all here and inevitably you will
get people with diverse opinions but you
will also get situations where styles
may rub other people on the team the
wrong way now most of the time this is
not a big deal because this this is a
volunteer thing and most people don't
take themselves that seriously but you
know people can get pretty passionate
about this is something everyone is
doing with their free time so professor
Maggie Neal did a whole session on this
at our last training and I do recommend
that if you have a chance that you take
a look at her presentation on the web
but I think the best thing to do to deal
with a situation is that everyone on the
team needs to take some responsibility
for taking care of other people on the
team so if you notice that someone is
being really quiet or you know
consistently cannot be heard on the team
you know make a point of saying gee we
haven't heard from you know Lauren so
try to try to make sure be aware of that
because you're always going to have a
situation where certain people are going
to be more dominant than other folks on
the team and you know the way to make
sure that people don't end up feeling
marginalized and dropping off the team
in the worst case because it does happen
is to make sure that everyone pays
attention to what's going on during team
meetings and if even if it means you
know taking you timeout and speaking to
someone one-on-one offline so that's my
best recommendation it's the same advice
I would give it to any kind of team
situation and it's even more critical in
a volunteer situation so so David's
gonna kick off the next answer for us
at teams sometimes experience what we
call the slump in the middle where the
project kind of seems to lose momentum
mean this typically is a six-month
project some projects go on for much
longer and so so David can you give us
some ideas on kind of how to keep the
team going during the time we've already
talked about how important it is to
clearly identify what you're going to
try to do and to get a commitment from
the client as to their commitment of
time and if you have those things in
place I think that that that is really
going to help you move through and avoid
a slump I think it's important to keep
timelines short my experience working
with business school alums is that they
can do pretty well for a short period of
time but if you try to do something that
goes nine months or a year year and a
half other things intervene all kinds of
things personal work and so on so what I
like to see is short timelines that are
doable and and being clear on exactly
what the deliverables are for each of
the team members and my sense of this is
that somebody who's not getting the work
done in two weeks is not going to get
the work done if you give them two more
weeks so if you're having somebody who's
having problems keeping up with the
group sit down with them one-on-one find
out what's going on and have a
heart-to-heart on whether or not it's
viable for them to continue I also like
to see overlapping skill sets on teams
so that if somebody is not able to work
at the rate that they thought they could
you have somebody who can pick up things
and that can avoid a slump because you
actually don't have the whole dip
because of one team member
I guess one thing I'd say is uh probably
it's good to have what happens is
sometimes there's a flurry of activity
and then you're waiting for something to
happen you know you may be waiting
oftentimes you end up doing surveys and
it takes some time for people to respond
and for you to understand whether
they're ready to talk to you or to get
responses back as well I've had two
projects where that's happened and
you're sort of saying okay you know
you're kind of waiting for the data
you're not sure what to do and the team
can lose a lot of energy doing that and
I think it's kind of useful to maintain
some contact it's easy to sort of say oh
we'll just wait till we hear back and
then the energy of the team can kind of
die down
- even if it's for a half-an-hour
conference call every week to kind of
keep that up and just say has anyone had
any other thoughts have we done any
secondary research or in any other area
that might have some bearing upon this
you know apart from the surveys or
whatever data we're waiting for
so to find some way to use the time
usefully still I think that can help
amplify your point I think it's
important to continue to have regular
meetings and hopefully in your project
plan you've designed some backup tasks
so that when there is that kind of lull
in the project that there's some you
know research that can still be done or
some interviews that can be conducted
try to overlap those tasks so you don't
get a situation where you're just
waiting for data okay so this is a kind
of a key question I'm going to have
David to kick this one off during the
course of a project sometimes someone
chooses to either drop off the team or
stop showing up for an extended period
of time can you give us an example of
where this happened and what your
suggestions are on dealing with it I can
give you an example of where this
happened it was in the project that we
just finished for the Oakland Zoo in the
middle of the project the Oakland Zoo
hired one of our team members as their
CEO Oh
I never saw access a job placement
agency but it worked for prevents so
what did we do well it's actually kind
of interesting because it was a bit of
one of those things where the the board
consistently has wanted act involved
with the zoo to try to get the executive
director what they don't have the guts
to tell him to do and I think that
you'll find the act teams brought in
innocently in many cases with with
hidden hidden agendas on the part of the
board on the part of the IDI trying to
fire the board or to bring about some
other change that they can't seem to do
more in a more straightforward way in
our case what we did is we stopped
communicating with Vince because we felt
that we were going to be talking to them
about things that might be controversial
and we wanted a chance to talk to the
leadership of the organization first
fortunately what I talked about before
of having some overlapping skills we had
a second team member who was a great
number cruncher and Vincent she had been
doing wonderful analysis of the
historical trends and what would happen
if they kept going the way they were
which as I mentioned before would be out
of business and so she picked up the
pace and she took over and and we
finished off the project now I do hope
that our plan is being instituted in a
way the Oakland Zoo hadn't instituted
our three previous projects for them
because we got our guy there I'm
interested to check back and see how
it's worked out this is probably that's
probably a more unusual situation
situations come up we had a team member
once who who had an accident and you
know there's nothing something can do
you can't do anything about that and
you're out of commission for a month and
what do you do and one of the things
that helps is actually team sizes you
know sometimes it is unmanageable to
have you know that the agendas of
everybody line up when you have 16
members but it's nice for those
situations when they do you know get
pregnant or have to move away or you
know something
that happens when a personal situation
comes up so what I found generally is
that you know what you find is most of
the team members are willing to just
take on a little bit extra in the case
where you have very specialized tasks
then yes you're hoping you have backup
because otherwise you're screwed but you
can always come to a crew and ask her
for another person or you know to get
some extra help I think that's another
thing you can do it's a little tricky
because if it happens midway in the
project there's so much learning that
has gone on that it can be challenging
but that's one place where having a team
more 5-6 members or so does help where
you can take up some of the slack of the
work and often what happens is at least
a couple of times it's happened with me
the team member when they come back are
more than willing to put in an extra
effort towards the end so then the other
people can relax a little bit that's
what tends to happen mostly leader when
someone I've been most familiar with the
the flake someone just doesn't show up
for a couple meetings is for a team
leader to directly address it find out
what's going on and then tell them
everyone else this person's not showing
up because of this because I don't it's
not great for morale when geez you're
waiting 15 minutes is he going to show
this time it's sort of a downer to start
every meeting on is this person going to
be here so just address it yeah and
actually that's something that I
recommend all the project leaders do
especially in the first meeting is find
out you know what people's commitment
really I mean I do they have the stamina
for a four to six month project and kind
of established that right away because
it's different when there's an accident
but often people really have planned
absences and make sure you find out you
know we had a we had a team member who
was studying for the bar so we knew we
were going to lose her assumed weight in
the project we had another situation
where you know we had someone who
probably didn't remember his class year
who was a gray hair and he was a very
valuable member of the project but he'd
been made it very clear that he only had
you know two months and that he was
going to be you know on an extended
vacation in Europe after that so we
really took advantage
in the first two months and you know I
think that's fine you just need to be
realistic this is a volunteer kind of
thing and so you know be upfront about
it communicate really clearly with your
project leader if you're if you're going
to be out if there's some emergency at
work what have you so that your project
leader and the rest of the team can try
to balance the remaining tasks and you
can still have a good project and a good
result for your client so the project
leader role does involve quite a bit of
extra work and so the question I have
for the panels what can your team do for
all the project leaders out there what
can your team do to make your life
easier which is at that first team
meeting when you're sort of dividing up
into two sub teams inform telling the
team leader telling the whole group
these are things that I have experienced
doing these are things I want to get
experience doing these are things I know
that I'm bringing to the team so that
just as your example David with you know
you had two people working on data and
one dropped off you still have one doing
that just that redundancy I think the
biggest recommendation I have about
making it project leaders like easier I
think it's very similar to what we do
elsewhere as community volunteers show
up so if you agree to be on the team
come to all the meetings make an
extraordinary effort do your
negotiations with your family in your
workplace beforehand so you can show up
and make the most nothing's worse than
having a team meeting and half the
people aren't there and then do the work
so if you agree to take a task on do it
do it in a timely fashion and then
contribute ideas
so bring yourself try to carve out the
time for it and bring all of yourself
when you are in those meetings and it
sounds pretty fundamental but I would
say that every team letter leader if
they had those three things happen it
would go very smoothly actually in terms
of doing stuff you know doing the work
and being coming to the meeting prepared
so if there is a
something to be discussed then you know
make sure you've read the material or
done the work that's required that to
make sure you know we it's really
difficult sometimes to find that one are
in the week or two hours that everybody
can meet from their busy lives and you
don't want to really spend that sort of
updating people and what's happened and
you know be there on time that's the
other thing every ten minute counts you
know if it's if you're meeting around
lunchtime to get your lunch before you
come to the meeting it helps it's little
stuff like that and then the other thing
that can help is actually some some
sense of rotating responsibilities in
terms of you know if we're taking notes
it kind of it's it's easier for
everybody I think if that's on some sort
of a rotating basis so one person is not
always doing the more kind of routine
work of just note-taking setting up
meetings whatever it might be so
sometimes that works and helps as well
with the team clear communication so so
yes the best thing for you to do is to
show up do what you committed to do but
if you can't because you know life
happens make sure you let your team
leader know that you're not going to be
doing what you were assigned and make
sure you let that your your project
leader know as soon as possible
so that your project leader has an
opportunity to to reassign the tasks and
to try to deal with that you know the
recommendation I don't have to project
leaders of course is to build in
redundancy and build some slack in so
that there is that capacity to take over
if somebody has some you know emergency
business meeting they have to fly off
somewhere and just will not be able to
come through on something but clear
communication is really really important
so you know don't leave it till the next
meeting to say oh gee I didn't do it